wir haben etwas neues für euch bei
Tatort Deutschland es gibt zu einem der
Fälle die wir hier schon ausführlich
behandelt haben nämlich ein Update der
Täter ist aus der Haft entlassen worden
und bei mir sitzt Laura Gehrmann grüß
Dich Laura hallo es geht um den Fall des
Parkhaus Mordes haben wir ihn genannt
wir haben in den Podcast auch glaube ich
mit sowas wie Hammer Mord bezeichnet
einen Fall der in München für viele
viele Schlagzeilen gesorgt hat gib uns
in ein zwei Sätzen vielleicht noch ein
Update was in dem Fall damals geschehen
ist ja sehr gerne also es war 2006 im
Sommer da wurde die
Multimillionären Charlotte Böhringer im
Penthaus über ihrem Parkhaus mit
mehreren Hammerschlägen wirklich total
ermordet
24 Schläge waren das glaube ich laut
Anklageschrift damals und der
Verdächtige der dann auch schuldig
gesprochen wurde war im Prinzip der
Neffe der so die Rekonstruktion der
Staatsanwaltschaft dagegen gekämpft hat
dass er enterbt wurde der hat total
erotisch chaotisch gelebt und sah laut
Anklage damit dass alles geklärt dass er
dann nun Erbe war und ist korrigiere
mich zu lebenslange Haft mit der
Feststellung der besonderen Schwere der
Schuld verurteilt worden genau das war
dann 2008 da saß er dann also schon eine
ganze Weile in U-Haft und ist dann
2018 zu dieser Haftstrafe verurteilt
worden die jetzt nach einem juristischen
Alltag was in Jahren gerechnet
lebenslang ist ja nie lebenslang bei uns
in Deutschland was eigentlich bedeutet
hätte
ja eigentlich 25 Jahre so und nun ist es
aber so dass man sagen kann okay nach 15
Jahren kann man schon mal beantragen
vielleicht doch vorzeitig entlassen zu
werden aufgrund guter Führung und keinen
weiteren Auffälligkeiten in der Zeit und
ja jetzt sind 17 Jahre rum und jetzt ist
der Benedikt
auf einen Fuß hatte ich das überrascht
ja komplett okay also wir sind auch
selber heute von der Nachricht komplett
überrascht worden wer wussten dass das
Thema freigegangen für ihn auf jeden
Fall da ist und dass er auch so nach und
nach wieder integriert werden soll aber
das ist jetzt so schnell geht hat mir
nicht gedacht das musst du uns gerne
noch mal erklären Laura also wie man das
jetzt liest und hört ist es so dass er
hätte bald frei kommen sollen aber man
nicht genau wusste dass er heute frei
kommt wie sind diese Abläufe jetzt
zustande gekommen fakt ist es gibt so
eine mindest verbüßungsdauer die sind
bei ihm 17 Jahre auf die wurde
festgesetzt und die werden jetzt
eigentlich Mitte Mai diesen Jahres
abgelaufen und daher aber eh so ein paar
freigegangstage sage ich mal auf seinem
Konto gutgeschrieben hatte wurden ihm
die jetzt angerechnet und er ist jetzt
halt Ende April schon freigelassen
worden
wer den Fall gleich noch mal hören will
da weisen wir auch noch mal darauf hin
er wird feststellen der ist eben aber
komplizierter und deshalb auch so
spannend weil bei dieser Freilassung
geht sie jetzt nicht um die Schuld
sondern das ist im Prinzip die
Feststellung des Gerichts dass der Mann
seine Strafe jetzt abgesessen hat aber
warum durch was in der Indizienkette war
der Fall denn damals eigentlich so
umstritten
na wie du schon sagst es gab nur eine
Indizienkette und es gab keine Beweise
das heißt es konnte eigentlich dem äh
Benedikt hot nie wirklich nachgewiesen
werden in eindeutigen hinweisen oder
auch Spuren dass er seine Tante
umgebracht hat aber diese Indizienkette
die die Staatsanwaltschaft und auch die
Ermittler damals so aufgestellt haben
hat halt zum Großteil gegen ihn
gesprochen und sich sozusagen wie so
eine Kette um sein Hals gelegt und ihn
eigentlich als einzigen Täter ausgemacht
weshalb das mit Fragezeichen Zahlen zum
Teil sogar als viel Urteil diskutiert
wurde in in Deutschland damals genau
also der Benedikt hat bestreitet bis
heute dass er seine Tante umgebracht hat
und
ist auch immer noch selber glaube ich
immer noch schockiert darüber dass er
damals so krass verurteilt wurde und
wird dadurch auch weiterhin dafür
kämpfen dass er da irgendwie entschädigt
wird du hast ihn ja kennengelernt im
Zuge der Recherche das kann man im
Podcast ja auch toll hören der klingt
schon sehr besonders sehr gesprächig den
kriegt man kaum gestoppt welchen
Eindruck hast du damals von ihm
mitgenommen ja das ist ein wahnsinnig
vitaler junger Mann Anfang 40 der
natürlich den Großteil seines Lebens
dahinter Gittern in der JVA Straubing
verbracht hat
der mit vollem Elan glaube ich dafür
kämpfen wird irgendwann beweisen zu
können dass er sie nicht umgebracht hat
seiner Meinung nach wer jetzt neugierig
geworden ist soweit also unser Update
wird im Anschluss direkt diesen Fall
noch mal hört darin auch Laura Germann
wieder und noch andere spannende
utongeber wenn euch das gefallen hat
dass wir mal so einen Update geben und
auch neu hochladen sagt uns gerne
Bescheid und der Podcast Bild.de oder
bei Instagram die entsprechende Links
posten wir dann auch noch mal in den
Show Notes und damit erstmal soweit für
heute
[Musik]
ich bin ein rechtskräftig verurteilter
Mörder
so formal korrekt weil die halt der
Auffassung waren dass irgendeiner und am
besten ich eingesperrt werden soll für
den Mord an meiner Tante
Benedikt genannt Benze spricht da über
sich selbst 16 Jahre Knast sitzt der in
der JVA Stadelheim ab in diese Episode
von Tatort Deutschland machen wir uns
gemeinsam ein Bild davon ob bei diesem
aufsehenerregenden Fall am Ende ein
Unschuldiger hinter gitterwandelte ich
bin Sky du Mont und freue mich dass ihr
wieder dabei seid heute der Parkhaus
Mord
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
[Musik]
mein Name ist Laura Germann ich arbeite
seit mehr als zehn Jahren für Bild und
habe natürlich viel mit mordprozessen
und auch anderen Fällen vor Gericht zu
tun die immer wahnsinnig spannend sind
und einer dieser Fälle ist der Fall von
Charlotte Böhringer
Reporterin Laura Gehrmann blättert durch
die archivierten Artikel der BILD am 15
Mai 2006 wird in München die als
Parkhaus Millionärin bezeichnete
Charlotte Böhringer eiskalt und mit 24
Hammerschlägen in ihrer Wohnung ermordet
der Verdacht der Ermittlungsbehörden
fällt auf den Neffen der Ermordeten auf
Benedikt tot
94 Tage dauerte Indizienprozess im
Anschluss wird Benedikt Tod wegen Mordes
verurteilt wegen der Schwere seiner Tat
wird er bis 2028 im Gefängnis bleiben
aber es gibt keine stichhaltigen Beweise
für seine Tat und bis heute betreut
Benedikt Benze
[Musik]
die bild-reporterin ist vom deutschen
Rechtssystem überzeugt sie kann sich
nicht vorstellen dass ein Mensch auf
Basis von Indizien vielleicht sogar
unschuldig im Gefängnis sitzt es lässt
dir keine Ruhe es ist Boarding für ihren
Flug Berlin München in München wird sie
heute mit den am Prozess beteiligten
Menschen und dem vermeintlichen Täter
sprechen
Termin Nummer 1 für die Reporterin
München Innenstadt der Fachanwalt für
Strafrecht Peter Witting der verteidige
von benzed der Rechtsanwalt arbeitet
seit 38 Jahren als Strafverteidiger
erregt sichtlich um Fassung
die Tat soll am 15 Mai 2006 begangen
worden sein in der Zeit um 18 19 Uhr
19:30 Uhr in der Parkgarage angekommen
sein er muss nach Auffassung der
Ermittlungsbehörden Handschuhe getragen
haben er muss also präpariert gewesen
sein für einen Anschlag gleichsam gegen
seine Tante
er war bewaffnet mit einem unbekannten
Gegenstand er soll dann vor der
Eingangstür der Wohnung her Charlotte
Böhringer gewartet haben wohl wissen
dass sie gegen 19:30 Uhr üblicherweise
an einem Montag das war Montag na in zum
Stammtisch im Tal geht und
Charlotte bühringer war ein Begriff die
Wohnung zu verlassen so die These und
Benedikt tot hat dann 24 mal auf seine
Tante eingeschlagen bis sie am Ende
eines kleinen Flurs also vom Eingang
Richtung Wohnungs anderes zu liegen
kommt und dort verstirbt ich war und das
war immer mein meine Überzeugung soweit
man als Verteidiger überzeugt sein kann
und darf dass er nicht der Täter ist das
ist deutlich die bild-reporterin bedankt
sich und macht sich auf den Weg zum
Münchner Büro ihrer Zeitung dort
erwartet Sie Axel Petermann Petermann
war Polizeibeamter zuletzt
stellvertretender Leiter der
Mordkommission in Bremen mittlerweile
ist der bekannt als Bestsellerautor und
Profiler er wird in vielen Fällen als
Experte zu Rate gezogen die Eltern und
der Bruder von wenzelot haben sich an
ihn gewandt und ihn gebeten sich die
Akten des Falls noch einmal genauer
anzusehen ich bin der Auffassung dass
mir die Spuren einer Tat ganz ganz viel
über den Ablauf des Verbrechens
berichten
[Musik]
in der Nähe des Münchner Stadtzentrums
befindet sich das Isar Parkhaus das
ehemalige Boehringer Parkhaus das ist
ein schlichtes 5 geschossiges
Nutzgebäude unscheinbar alterslos aber
in der obersten Etage befindet sich noch
heute das Penthouse von Charlotte
Böhringer dem Mordopfer
Reporterinnen und Profiler betreten
gemeinsam die Wohnung
riesige Räume mit teilweise
kuppelförmigen Decken alles wird
herrschaftlich modern und vielleicht ein
wenig zu grell der Boden heller Marmor
und die vielen Fenster sorgen für
lichtdurchflutete Zimmer hier hat Frau
Böhringer zum Tatzeitpunkt als Single
gewohnt auf einem großen Tisch im
Wohnzimmer breiten Laura Gehrmann und
der Ex Polizist Tatort Fotos aus auf
einem ist die Frauenleiche in eine
riesigen Blutlache zu sehen also ich bin
zunächst erstmal davon ausgegangen dass
der Gutachter Recht hatte mit seiner
Angabe dass der Täter Handschuhe
getragen hatte und es fängt damit an das
gesagt wurde an der Eingangstür das kann
man hier auf diesem Foto ganz schön
sehen dass die Eingangstür hier oben ist
der Spion habe sich der Abdruck eines
Handschuhs gefunden und dieser Abdruck
ist dann gesichert worden und das ist
jetzt hier das Bild des vom
vermeintlichen handschuhabdruck wenn man
sich das aber sehr genau anschaut dann
wird man sehen dass es doch recht
unregelmäßige Konturen sind manche sind
groß manche sind klein manche sind
langgezogen das war so der erste Zweifel
den ich hatte dass ich dachte mensch das
ist so unregelmäßig muss das überhaupt
kein Handschuh sein und dann wurde eine
zweite Spur für die eine Fernschuss
gehalten und dann habe ich mir die dann
angeguckt und vergrößert und das hat
mich nicht überzeugt und deswegen habe
ich mir Sachverständige gesucht die eben
halt sich speziell mit solchen Spuren
auseinandersetzen und die haben dann
gesagt es ist ein Fingerabdruck besser
gesagt hier Frühstück wahrscheinlich der
Abdruck einer ankante die Reporterin
hakt nach wie wichtig ist es denn
feststellen ob der Täter Klausur an
hatte oder nicht also für das Gericht
war sehr sehr wichtig es behauptete der
Täter sei vorbereitet gewesen und diese
handschuhabdruck der war letztendlich
entscheidend dafür die besondere Schwere
der Schuld zugesprochen bekam
kann das sein ein handschuhabdruck ist
die Grundlage für den längsten
Indizienprozess Münchens denn erst am 12
August 2008 wird das Urteil gegen benzod
gesprochen schuldig
Laura Gehrmann denkt nach die Aussagen
von Verteidiger Witting und Profiler
Petermann machen sie skeptisch die
Journalistin muss nun auch die andere
Seite hören sie besucht Rechtsanwalt Dr
Alexander Stevens um sich die Sichtweise
der Anklage schildern zu lassen Stevens
war zur Zeit des Prozesses
rechtsanwaltsanwärter bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft München mit dem
Parkhaus Mord kam nicht in Berührung und
weil ich zur Zeit der Verhandlung des
Parkhaus Mannes bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft meine Wahlstation
gemacht hatte natürlich kriegt man dann
auch das ein oder andere mit was man
vielleicht als Außenstehender nicht mehr
bekommen hätte und damit war das
Interesse geweckt und Jahre später habe
ich einen Buch geschrieben bei dem es um
perfekte Morde ging und deswegen habe
ich mich also diesen
diesen Fall angenommen da sehr sehr
tiefgreifend recherchiert Urteil
natürlich gelesen auch Akten gelesen und
mir dann ein eigenes Bild gemacht und
diese Geschichte zu Papier gebracht auf
die Frage ob Benedikt Bentz schuldig ist
antwortet dr Stevens sehr bestimmt also
dass er zurecht hinter Gittern sitzt
davon bin ich zu 100% definitiv
überzeugt doch damit alleine gibt sich
bild-reporterin Gehrmann nicht zufrieden
sie will wissen wie die Polizei beim
Verhör von Benze vorgegangen ist
zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte die Münchner
Mordkommission nachweislich sich
fortgebildet in den USA zu einer
gewissen Methode der sogenannten read
Methode und die macht also folgendes da
gibt es nicht nur den good cop und im
badkop diese Methode kennt man ja der
Eine schreit und ist dann für den
Beschuldigten für den Betroffenen dann
diese aggressive Person vor der Angst
hat und der das oder nette der Kumpel zu
dem man sich dann irgendwie hingezogen
fühlt und sich dann gegebenenfalls
öffnet so die Theorie bei der
read-methode ist es noch eine ganze Ecke
krasser und das einfach mal ganz kurz
übers Knie zu brechen versucht man da
den Leuten letztlich die Tat einzureden
indem man sie Möbel macht ja die werden
über stundenlang vernommen und denen
werden dann auch Dinge in Aussicht
gestellt die wenn Sie die Tat den
einräumen niemals zutreffen werden dann
werden Alternativen vorgegeben ja mit
gesagt ne du warst doch da und da aber
du hast ja doch eigentlich gar nichts
Schlechtes gedacht also das Messer in
die Hand genommen hast du wolltest doch
damit eigentlich nur irgendwie schnitzen
oder irgendwas also sie geben ihm
Alternativen vor die er dann aufnimmt
und wenn er die dann auf eine wissen Sie
sie haben den Täter und dann gehen sie
halt richtig hart mit dem ins Gefecht
dass man ihm letztlich ein Geständnis
das ist das das eigentliche Ziel der mit
Methode dann aus der Nase gezogen hätte
das gibt's ja eben nicht aber sah sich
wohl genötigt und ich finde das Wort
genötigt passt da auch ganz gut
Dinge zu sagen und sich dadurch in
eklatante Widersprüche zu verstricken
aus denen er nicht mehr rauskamen
nach dieser Aussage zu den
Vernehmungsmethoden der Ermittler muss
die bild-reporterin mit der
entscheidenden Person sprechen sie wird
wenze treffen und begibt sich dafür auf
eine zweistündige Fahrt von München zur
JVA Straubing
mit der Erlaubnis für das Interview
trifft sie den Verurteilten alternd und
hager sitzt der Folie seine grau-blauen
Augen zeigen keine Wut aber auch keine
Freude Laura Gehrmann setzt sich ihm
gegenüber und Benze beginnt zu erzählen
was kurz nach seiner Verhaftung geschah
ich dachte ja tatsächlich vielleicht in
einer halben Stunde dann werde ich
wieder entlassen es sind ja so viele
Widersprüche evoziert wurden
natürlich habe ich den bösen Willen
gesehen aber irgendwie habe ich mir
gedacht das kann eigentlich kann das
nicht sein weil das sind doch die guten
und also jeder Widerspruch der mir dann
vorgeworfen wurde das war das war
evoziert seitens der Mitleid entweder
haben sowas nicht kapiert oder sie
wollten was nicht kapieren und und und
dann gab's Themenkreise wo ich dann
absichtlich verwirrt werden sollte
irgendwie die die die was mir jetzt
einfällt die Kombination unseres Tresors
und ich sollte jetzt dann halt den
Tresor dann öffnen oder oder geistig
öffnen und dann ging es darum wie viel
Umdrehungen dort
dahin Stopp zurück ich meine wen
interessiert es aber natürlich dann als
schafhocke ich da und konzentriere mich
schneller das muss schneller gehen
schneller noch mal von vorne schneller
nein das war nicht wichtig noch mal
irgendwas heißt hier das war nicht
richtig und sie sind irgendwann einmal
sind sie tatsächlich so weitermachen
soll dann mit und dann hoffen sie okay
jetzt ist es vorbei so nein das stimmt
nicht das sollte doch bestimmt ich kann
mein Interesse an nicht ihr und was tut
es im übrigen zur Sache
das müssen Sie schon uns überlassen was
wir fragen ja also das sind halt so
Kleinigkeiten und die Uhrzeit war schon
beschlossene Sache der Tot verlässt
dieses Gebäude nie wieder also für die
war das klar nur war das dann doch nicht
klar na ja und es hat sich dann halt
immer in Wellen hochgeschaut bis ich
dann gesagt habe mit dem rede ich nicht
mehr also ich gehe jetzt also ich war
dann tatsächlich auch schon aufgestanden
ja und dann genau in dem Moment kommt so
von der Seitentür ein und also der war
halt schon sehr sehr viele der mich sehr
freundschaftlich und sehr sehr liebevoll
wieder beruhigt und alles in nervös und
so weiter und ich soll doch bitteschön
ein bisschen nachsichtig seinen Kollegen
geben gegenüber der ist auch über
nächtigt etc also wie gesagt also das
haben die natürlich schon sehr geschickt
gemacht dann sind Details verschiedene
Stränge miteinander vermengt worden
und es kam natürlich kein eindeutiges
Ergebnis dann raus und ich habe versucht
wieder die Stränge zu entwickeln habe
gesagt schauen Sie das war an dem Tag
das war an dem Tag kein Wunder dass wir
irgendwie wieder andere Ergebnisse haben
ja ich soll nicht so gescheite reden
sagen ihr schmeißt alles in einem Topf
von der kommt nichts aus dabei ist kein
Wunder deine Lieben Banane weil ich zwei
Tage nicht geschlafen habe aber ich
versuche mich zu konzentrieren
nach dieser Prozedur wird dem jungen
Mann verkündet dass er nun eigentlich
erst festgenommen ist
das war nicht mehr so eine Überraschung
weil ich jetzt ja eigentlich schon
wissen müssen wie Stunden vorher
ich habe das bloß irgendwie nicht aus
mir rausgebracht
trotzdem Glauben zu schenken dass ich da
sitze um zu helfen immer ich war halt
auf psychisch dann doch in einer
Ausnahme Situation also zwei Tage kaum
geschlafen kaum gegessen dann sind sie
ganz erfahrenen Leuten gegenüber dieser
aufs Kreuz legen wollen die Journalistin
ist auf der Rückfahrt nach München
nachdenklich und im Zweifel wie sie die
so gegensätzlichen Aussagen einordnen
soll sie will den Fall noch besser
verstehen
dazu gehört es mehr über das Opfer zu
erfahren wie hat Charlotte Böhringer
gelebt wie war ihre Beziehung zu ihrem
Neffen Benze dafür trifft sie sich mit
Brigitte klein einer guten Freundin der
Ermordeten Geschäftsfrau
gemeinsam stehen sie vor der Pizzeria
Lago di Garda die sich direkt neben dem
Parkhaus befindet da ging unsere
Charlotte immerhin da war das Parkhaus
dann ist sie runter und vom Kochen hat
sie nicht viel gehalten also ab ins
Lager die Garda Böhringer
öfter zu Feierlichkeiten auch in ihrem
Penthouse eingeladen ein zwei Mal hat
sie das gemacht aber da war sie auch zu
nervös sie wollte das perfekt machen
dass sie hat dann lieber in die Kneipe
eingeladen das war ja angenehmer als bei
sich zu Hause okay aber die
Berichterstattung hatte das Mordopfer
Charlotte Böhringer auch als sehr
gesellig und trinkfreudig bezeichnet
genau also gut und gerne einen gebärcher
würde ich sagen sie sah sehr gut aus und
es wurde jetzt Haltung berichtet darüber
mit Fotos sind und wo ist die Bussi sie
hat dieses Leben sehr genossen und
Benedikt haben wir öfter mal
kennengelernt er hat sie öfter begleitet
und er war auch ihr lieblingsnevel
später kam ja dann im Laufe der Zeit
dass das der Neffe verdächtigt wurde und
wir waren erst mal alle völlig
fassungslos natürlich gab es auch Leute
die gesagt haben der arme Kerl wurde von
ihr hin und her geschickt und muss die
Jura studieren und wollte das nicht und
die Freundin wurde nicht akzeptiert
möglicherweise hat sie ja auch auf dem
Geldhahn gesessen also die Spekulation
da haben doch einige angetreten die sie
auch kannten weil man befürchtet hat
dass auf seine Bedürfnisse und seine
Wünsche von ihrer Seite möglicherweise
zu wenig Rücksicht genommen wird die
Reporterin hört in den Aufnahmen aus der
JVA nach was Benze dazu gesagt hat hätte
er überhaupt einen Grund gehabt seine
Tante zu ermorden Komplex also meine
Tante war eine hochkomplexe Frau wenn
sie fröhlich war war sie vielleicht zu
fröhlich für die Begriffe andere Leute
wenn sie traurig war aber sie dann halt
auch gleich melancholisch wenn gemocht
hat hat sie geliebt und wenn sie halt
dann
nicht gemacht hat hat sie halt gehasst
alles in Ordnung und einschätzbar für
mich ich meine ich habe sie mein ganzes
Leben lang gekannt also von von
Kleinkind ist bei Ihnen an also meine
Tante wird ja jetzt leider fast
durchgehend negativ dargestellt was ja
nicht so ist ich meine das ist halt dann
das was vielleicht hängen bleibt bei
denen die sie nicht gekannt haben also
zunächst war meine Tante eine sehr
liebende und großzügige Frau und sie hat
halt aber auch Ansprüche gestellt ja und
sie hat
ihre Vorstellungen nicht
erfüllt wurden auch kein Plattform und
genommen Benedikt nimmt sie in Schutz
vor den negativen Darstellungen in der
Presse die Reporterin vermutet Kalkül
will er betonen dass er gar keinen Grund
hatte so eine Tat zu begehen
Charlotte Böhringer war Erben und
Geschäftsfrau zu der das Böhringer
Parkhaus Sam Tankstelle und Werkstatt
gehört die Witwe hatte zurzeit der Tat
ihre beiden Neffen angestellt bänze als
Assistent der Geschäftsführung und
seinen Bruder Mate als Schichtleiter und
den trifft die bild-reporterin in genau
dem Parkhaus über dem der Mord geschah
an dem Tag hatte ich ja Spätschicht
beginnt um 15:45 Uhr ich war kurz davor
da die Mitarbeiter der Frühschicht haben
gesagt dass sie meine Tante nicht
erreicht haben also der hat sich den
ganzen Tag nicht gerührt und wir wussten
nicht wo sie ist oder warum sie nicht da
ist ich kann mich noch daran erinnern
ich habe es dann am Handy angerufen hier
von der Türkei und
habe auch das Klingeln auf der anderen
Seite gehört die Unruhe wurde wo er
immer größer wird später waren wir auch
oben auf dem Dach weil wir gedacht haben
vielleicht hat sie hinten bei der
Waschküche das Fenster offen gelassen
zum Lüften dass man vielleicht auch in
die Wohnung reinkommt
wir waren alle Fenster zu und da es war
auch nichts zu sehen ja ich war ja auch
perfekt mein Bruder hat sich übergeben
ich muss ja auch gar nicht ob es einen
Mord ist oder ein Unfall dass sie die
Treppe vielleicht runter gestürzt ist in
unzähligen Zeitungsartikeln die über die
abscheuliche Tat veröffentlicht wurden
waren immer wieder Zweifel an der Schuld
von benzodot geäußert worden ein
wichtiger Punkt für den Schuldspruch war
der Todeszeitpunkt Profiler Axel
Petermann misst traut der korrekten
Bestimmung der Todeszeit der Mageninhalt
ist eine Möglichkeit
einzuschätzen wann jemand gestorben ist
und das Gericht war ja davon überzeugt
dass die Rechtsmediziner mit ihren
Berechnungen zum Mageninhalt Recht
hatten indem sie meinen Charlotte
Böhringer sei gegen 18:15 Uhr getötet
worden wir sind hier weil Charlotte
Böhringer Köpfe ihren Bruder hier im
Lago dicada gewesen ist dann hat er mir
Magen doch Hefte einer Speise gefunden
und die Menge hat man mit 100 Gramm
gemessen und diese Menge bedeutet dass
sie dreiviertel des ger bereits verdaut
hatte und ging davon aus dass es 400
Gramm Nudeln gewesen sein sollen die
bild-reporterin wirft ein das Charlotte
Böhringer eventuell weniger gegessen
haben könnte richtig Charlotte Böhringer
so hieß es sei eine sehr körperbewusste
Frau gewesen die auf ihre Figur geachtet
hat die
appetithügler Einnahmen also nochmal zur
Pizzeria Lago di Garda der Betreiber ist
bereit zwei unterschiedlich große
Portionen des nudelgerichts zu servieren
das Charlotte Böhringer als letzte
Mahlzeit zu sich genommen haben soll
Axel Petermann kommentiert die beiden
unterschiedlichen Portionen nun haben
wir zwei Portionen hier eine große eine
kleine das Gericht hat angenommen dass
die Portion so groß gewesen ist
entspricht das was Charlotte Böhringer
gegessen hat diesen genau und das wäre
zu viel das werde ich zu viel
und nie gegessen alleine und dann kam
nicht in Frage nein genau dann gehen wir
ja nicht in Frage also man muss sagen es
lässt sich überhaupt nicht feststellen
wann Charlotte Böhringer gestorben ist
und mein Fazit ist dass viele der vom
Gericht angeführten Indizien nicht
schlüssig sind und aus diesem Grunde
hätte Benedikt hat nie verurteilt werden
dürfen
die bildreporterin sitzt wieder im Büro
von Verteidiger Witting abgeschlossen
dass der sämtliche Spuren verfolgt
wurden dass die Ermittlungen weiche
weitreichend nein es ist von Anfang an
nur einseitig ermittelt worden nur gegen
Benedikt tot und zwar ab mindestens ab
dem Zeitpunkt seiner Festnahme am 16.05
abends um 19 Uhr
da waren die Ermittler sicher Sie haben
den richtigen und es ging nur um ihn und
nichts anderes
die Reporterin scrollt wieder durch ihre
Aufnahmen mit Benze wie hat er
eigentlich den Tag des Mordes erlebt
also es war ein Montag also das müsste
der
15.5.2006 gewesen sein
und ich war in der Früh
zu Hause geblieben
weil weil ich eine Grippe aus
ausgebrütet habe im Bett
ähm
also ich war den ganzen Tag nicht im
Geschäft an diesem Montag jedenfalls ist
meine Verlobte dann ähm gegen 5 ist sie
gegangen und ist dann abends gegen 22
Uhr oder
22:30 Uhr wieder heimgekommen und dann
kam der Dienstag ja Dienstag war dann
normaler Tag also ich meine ich war dann
auch schon
Filtern also ich war auf alle Fälle dann
ganz normal im Geschäft also bin halt
blöd bin halt ins Büro gefahren als wir
unsere Tante nicht erreicht haben
ihr Bruder und mein Bruder oder oder
auch unsere Mitarbeiter also das das war
jetzt Schichtführer zum Beispiel an der
Kasse also der hat z.B auch irgendetwas
gebraucht von meiner Tante auch was
gebraucht für eine Abrechnung ja wir
haben sie nicht erreicht das war jetzt
noch keinen keinen Anlass für
unmittelbare Sonne etwas regelmäßig
vorgekommen ist dass er bei spontan
weggefahren ist jetzt nicht länger aber
durchaus oder halt vielleicht irgendeine
längere Nacht gehabt sondern um die
Uhrzeit einfach noch nicht dran gehen
möchte Punkt fertig ja gut dann mach mal
besonderes und ähm da war es tatsächlich
schon
also später Nachmittag um mein Bruder
hat dann festgestellt an der Tür
horchend also das Handy angerufen hat
dass das Handy tatsächlich aus der aus
der Wohnung durchklingelt da war es
ruhig und da hat er das Handy klingeln
hören das war dann schon außergewöhnlich
und das war dann das war dann der
Hintergrund oder die die Ursache dafür
dass mir gesagt haben sollen jetzt
müssen wir handeln und weil ich einen
Schlüssel keine unmittelbaren
Zugangsschlüssel zur Wohnung gehabt habe
das sind wir einen eine der
Geschäftsführer gebeten vorbeizukommen
der den Schlüssel hatte und mit dem gehe
ich dann letztendlich um
kurz nach sieben dann in die Wohnung
gegangen
also es war auf alle Fälle bemerkenswert
hell also das ist ja dann ein gebrannt
auf der Festplatte
das sind ziemlich heller Raum der ja
auch kurz davor gestrichen wurde der
hell gestrichen wurde heller Marmor
Boden also also
meine Tante lag da in einer riesen
Blutlache und alles war voll mit Blut
ich bin tatsächlich äh jetzt noch nicht
davon ausgegangen dass sie tot sein
müsste also das erste war irgendwie
scheiße die ganze Zeit irgendwie die
Treppen runter die Haut weil das war
halt auch das waren die im Schlachthaus
anders kann es nicht sagen also
zumindest für meine Erfahrung für mich
war es halt extrem und ich oder es kann
auch nicht ich weiß es nicht mehr genau
jedenfalls bin ich angestoßen worden von
von dem Geschäftsführer schau mal nach
dem Puls daran kann ich mich noch
erinnern und dann bin ich hin habe mich
hingekniet und ich bin aber nicht einmal
dazu gekommen dass ich da irgendwie nach
dem Puls tatsächlich Suche weil als ich
angefasst hat habe ich gemerkt dass es
und natürlich kalt steif
ist nicht nicht wie Plastik also es ist
also da hat offensichtlich das Leben
gefehlt es bleibt am Ende nur eine Frage
die nach dem Motiv der Staatsanwalt gibt
der Reporterin bei ihrem Besuch zu
Protokoll er hat ein Motiv das
erstklassiger gar nicht sein könnte die
Problematik dass seine Tante ihn
regelrecht geschafft hatte er war nicht
mehr der stellvertretende
Geschäftsführer oder assistenter
Geschäftsführung nein es gab jetzt einen
neuen man hat ihm sogar den Schlüssel
weggenommen in eine größere Degradierung
gibt es ja gar nicht aber und jetzt
kommt der der very big point wenn sie
dort hatte über Jahre hinweg behauptet
Jura zu studieren und nicht nur das
sondern auch ein Jura Examen abgelegt zu
haben er hatte sogar ein
Weißwurstfrühstück ausgerichtet um das
ganze zu feiern das alles hat nicht
gestimmt es gab so ein Junge Studium das
hat er aber abgebrochen das war aber
eiserne Bedingungen der Tante für ihn
irgendwann mal die Geschicke dieser Park
dieses Parkhauses leiten zu dürfen das
haben sehr sehr viele Zeugen genauso
ausgesagt da haben wir noch einen Streit
der sehr unmittelbar vor der Tat
stattgefunden haben soll den wenn sie
tot aber zunächst in seiner Vernehmung
verschweigt und dann aber auch in einer
weiteren Vernehmung viel weiter
vordatiert auch das ist schon sehr
merkwürdig warum tut er das ja warum
spricht da nicht da die Wahrheit worum
ging es bei dem Streit ja bei dem Streit
ging es wohl um irgendwas profanes mit
den Reifen dass sie nicht richtig
aufgeräumt waren wie auch immer aber die
Tante auch sekundärisch wohl hat ihn da
also sehr zu minder gemacht und auch so
zumindest nach dem Feststellungen des
Gerichtsurteils da das Rufes bewiesen
und gesagt er soll nie wieder kommen
also ein solches Motiv Binde gleich äh
findet man selten und dann natürlich
die Tatsache dass er ein Millionen Erde
auf ihn warten würde wir reden ja hier
nicht von Kleinigkeiten und alle keine
Probleme und Sorgen wenn mit einem Male
mit dem Tod der Tante weg gewesen ich
habe keine Zweifel das ist Benzin top
war hat benzi gelogen war seine Tat
immer fekt der Wut auf seine Tante hatte
Charlotte Böhringer von dem Lügen
Gespinst ihres lieblingsneffen gewusst
der Bruder des verurteilten Mörders hat
dazu eine ganz eigene Meinung ganz klar
ich bin ja auch hier gewesen und also
ich hätte ja nicht herfahren müssen und
und wie alles drumrum konstruiert wurde
Zeitfenster ich war ja vor Ort ich war
ja Luftlinie hier fünf Stockwerke oder
vier Stockwerke tiefer da hätten sie
mich genauso rausnehmen können
wahrscheinlich haben sie halt dann
gesagt ach ja da hat es einen Streit
gegeben mit eingelagerten Reifen und
dann haben sie dann gesagt oh das ist äh
das ist elementar die haben sich
gestritten in der Familie und dann haben
die natürlich die in ihrem Kommissar
Mord Hand hoch auf Seite 28 Jahre
Familienangehöriger ist vorbei
und dann wird alles dann gegeben mein
Bruder hat ja auch gesagt dass er nicht
mehr studiert und das ist unsere Tante
gewusst hat das ist auch ein Prozess
geklärt worden ich meine die besten
Freundinnen und der Steuerberater haben
ja auch ausgesagt dass er nicht studiert
hat und im Urteil steht drinnen schaut
doch die Bürgermeister davon ausgegangen
hätte sein Studium erfolgreich beendet
da sagt der Zeugen das und im
Unterschied was anderes drin
Bowling Flug München Hamburg Laura
Germann reicht das Gehörte nicht um sich
ein abschließendes Gesamtbild zu machen
ich bin hier in Hamburg verabredet mit
dem Rechtsanwalt Gerhard schade der ist
dafür zuständig in dem Fall dass wieder
Aufnahmeverfahren zu bringen Gerhard ist
ein Spezialist für solche aussichtslose
Fälle und hat als einer der wenigen
überhaupt in der deutschen
Rechtsgeschichte ist schon ein paar mal
geschafft und wieder Aufnahmeverfahren
erfolgreich durchzusetzen hallo schönen
guten Tag hallo was ist so ungewöhnlich
an dem Fall ja ist deshalb schon ich
will nicht sagen ungewöhnlich wohl aber
zeichnet er sich dadurch aus dass er
wirklich
Beweise ins Feld führt also das Urteil
Indizien zusammenstellt die alle jeder
für sich
nicht unbedingt tragfähig werden
insgesamt aber meinte damals das Gericht
in der Gesamtschau es würde das
ausreichend um klar zu erklären dass
Bentley top der Täter ist und in der
Regel sind bei diesen Kapitalverbrechen
die Indizien zumindest an ein oder zwei
Punkten immer doch von großer
Eindeutigkeit das ist bei diesem Fall
nicht also jedes Indiz was hier auf
bensche trotz hinweisen soll ist für
sich genommen relativ neutral das
spricht auch das Gericht selber an in
dem schriftlichen notarztkunden aber zum
Schluss heißt es dann doch in der
Gesamtschau seines eindeutig und
Menschen dort seine Täter
warum sollte der Fall ihrer Meinung nach
wieder aufgerollt werden
ich hatte mich hierbei konzentriert auf
zwei Spuren die in der Gesamtschau der
Indizien von großer Bedeutung sein
sollen nämlich zwei DNA-Spuren an einem
Briefumschlag in dem sich das Testament
befand und des Weiteren eine Spur
der Rückseite der Jacke die Frau
Möhringer an dem Tage getragen hat
diese beiden Spuren sind nicht eindeutig
Menschen tot zuzuordnen es gibt mehrere
spurengeber vor allen Dingen jetzt aus
der Familie die auch in Betracht kommen
diese Spuren müssen auch nicht am Tag
Tage angebracht worden sein insgesamt
plädiere ich in dem Teil meines
Wiederaufnahme Antrags dafür dass diese
Spuren auch nicht hätten verwertet
werden dürfen das führt Laura Germann zu
ihrer abschließenden Frage
ihrer Meinung nach denn zurecht hinter
Gittern
also das kann ich relativ eindeutig
beantworten also wenn schon gehört dort
nicht hin die Reporterin fliegt zurück
nach Berlin sie muss weiter
recherchieren erst dann wird es in ihrem
Kopf Ruhe geben wenn dieser Mann seit 16
Jahren unschuldig im Gefängnis sitzt
muss etwas getan werden ist der schuldig
dann können die Angehörigen des Opfers
und auch das vermeintlichen Täters damit
abschließen und Erinnerungen an
Charlotte Böhringer Ruhe vor weiteren
Spekulationen finden
schön dass ihr in dieser Folge von
Tatort Deutschland dabei wart ich hoffe
wir hören uns bald wieder euer Sky du
[Musik]
ich bin von Süd nach nordgereist habe
Weggefährten von den Benedikt getroffen
habe seine Anwälte getroffen aber auch
Menschen die damals in der
Staatsanwaltschaft tätig waren und habe
wahnsinnig viele Eindrücke gesammelt
[Musik]
die Frage die sich mir stellt ist
natürlich nicht ist der schuldig oder
ist ja nicht schuldig weil die werden
wir nie beantworten können die werde ich
auch nie beantworten können die Frage
ist das Urteil so gerecht wie es gefällt
wurde und hätte ist jemand so gefällt
werden dürfen ist natürlich eine andere
und da kann ich jetzt nach meinem
Recherchen und nach meinen Gesprächen
sagen dass es auf jeden Fall Zweifel
daran gibt waren die Indizien wirklich
ausreichend um ihn für schuldig zu
befinden und da kann man auf jeden Fall
Zweifel dran haben und auch sagen dass
die Indizien nicht so eindeutig waren
dass das eine Grundlage dafür war ihn so
lange hinterher geht dann zu packen
Tatort Deutschland ist eine Produktion
aus den Wakeboard Studios Projektleitung
Simone terbrack Produktion Fabian
Scheffler Drehbuch Dieter Auras
Bildredaktion Laura Germann und Stefan
Netze